now in a brazen online speech disgraced
MP Fiona honor Sonia has begged voters
to let her keep her job despite the fact
she's a liar and a convicted criminal
who has disgraced not just her office
but the good people of Peterborough
honest Anja a solicitor with jail for
three months after lying about driving a
speeding car but despite her conviction
she was consistently refused to resign
one of her reasons because she needs her
77,000 MPs
sorry I'm sorry but we have a right to
expect our MPs to be held to higher
standards than the rest of us not least
because they make the laws that govern
us but most importantly because as a
member of the House they held much power
and responsibility in their hands
Fiona Anna Sonia is a convicted liar so
how can she be trusted with the power of
her office or to do the honorable thing
in politics when her first instinct in
life is to lie and save her own skin the
people of Peterborough deserve better
and let's hope the petition voters can
now sign to force a by-election will see
her kicked out she deserves to be well
Carol there is a due process under way
of the recall vote is is under way and
which is something that the House of
Commons itself it's standards committee
or something decides has to happen if an
MP has been convicted of something then
that were the less than a year's
sentence the the MP in question let
let's not condemn her out of her yeah I
do feel to say in her own defence again
from the outset I have maintained my
innocence I have not perverted the
course of justice
I have not colluded with my brother my
defence was never put across in the
media at all times they always put
forward the prosecution's case now I
have this opportunity I would like to
ask people have asked for my resignation
but what would you do if you knew you
were innocent would you sit back and
accept it would you accept the verdict
knowing in your heart of hearts that you
are
or would she fight to clear your name
she's not the first MP to be convicted
of a speeding offence nor is she the
last nor is she the first MP to lie nor
will she be the last that that was the
biggest little Tasha I've ever heard
from her because she said she has not
the chance to prove her yes she had she
had the chance in the High Court and she
had the chance in the appeal court and
Lord Levinson in the appeal court
expressed surprise that she turned up
without counsel without notes without
any evidence to think but also she she
she's talking like a victim yet she has
been convicted by two courts there's no
doubt to her guilt she also says I
didn't lose if it's a hanging with a man
yes let me make clear she said she
didn't pervert the course of justice she
did because she lie wilfully lied on a
form that said I was driving but the
bottom line is what she should have done
was held her hands up red star said yes
I was doing 43rd should have got three
points in a bit of a fight and by the
way let me just say I don't think she
should have gone to jail either I think
it wasn't a journaling offense it James
is about constraining dangerous people
that said I did lie yeah
should she remain an MP no could she
like okay she should have just paid the
fine for speeding took the pints and
shot and I just say well first of all I
mean I have to say I'm kind of impressed
you favor the brazenness of the woman I
could never imagine turning a hospital
Westminster with a tag he gotta give her
loan but actually at the end of the day
she's paid her debt to society and
surely we believe we've paid her debt
we've paid her debt to society she's
paid her debt with her liberty and her
time and also at the end of the day
surely we believe in second chances and
if we're saying Parliament do you want
to lie as you're sorry as you hoping I
would say 90% of politicians are like oh
why don't you possibly say in fact I'm
not convicted last hello I can name a
few of them who said we were gonna get
350 million
so we're talking about lying there's a
lot of politicians shouldn't have the
time but all the other I've just add to
that is at the end of day when saying
Parliament's should be made up of the
people there are a lot of people in this
country who have lied who have criminal
records I think she probably has a
different perspective actually maybe had
something else to offer now she's been
feeling whole argument in that is that I
was innocent well she's been before the
court the courts decided she's not a
missus she's guilty that's the system
she's a lawyer as well and she also knew
what she was doing and the requirements
on our end piece if you go through the
list you were terminal if you give her a
list one of me says behave with probity
and integrity now remember there was an
MP a Liberal MP called Chris hoon yeah I
mean he's I hope he's a very similar
story he he had swapped some points with
his wife or his wife had taken the
points for him say wouldn't lose his
license whopped his wife I'm the wife
decided she would get around back in the
end they both went to jail I think we're
missing the fundamental point in this
because we are human and sometimes
people do make mistakes and that's fine
but then there is also a think all
essentially gross misconduct in any role
and one of the things that's lacking at
the moment massively and it's crucially
important in Parliament is trust the
trust that we have into our MPs and at
the moment it's diminishing rapidly
adult yeah and when you have an MP that
wasn't convicted of speeding she was
convicted of perverting the course of
justice i lying that does nothing but
damage trust and clemency and integrity
in the MP and for that reason and that
reason alone to me I view that as gross
misconduct because if you're in public
office you are there and you are you are
supposed to act with integrity and
decency and honest and Trust as a king
called better than the rest of us and if
you've broken that trust by your own
deliberate actions you have no place and
off a I mean this woman has no respect
for the law she has no respect for her
office but the most important thing is
she has no respect for her constituents
and that's that's why but they're now
going through a process they're now
going for a process whereby I think
exact figure is six thousand nine
hundred and sixty-seven people got to go
to a polling station
I've gotta go they can't do it online or
send a letter they've got to go to a
polling station and say we want to get
rid of her now who knows how they get
that number but to spend half a million
pounds to find out why doesn't it have
to be the numbers that what they sent
for a constitutional change which says
that if an MP gets convicted of an
offense such as you know providing the
course of justice it's an automatic
dismissal not just from the path that
you but from the role of an MP and if it
was me I'd be campaigning for that
change this is fairly new itself there's
only ever been one case before this
Paisley junior in non-violence and that
didn't get so they didn't get the right
numbers now it's being just me to see
what happens I believe in second chances
myself and you know what perhaps she has
something else or you think it says a
lot about her character that when her
backs against the war the first thing
she does is trying to save her own skin
see had she held her hands up she'd have
got a fine but she didn't she chose as a
solicitor to willfully pervert the
course so look at the power that's in
her hands as an MP jus look at the
decisions that are you saying she can't
be trusted are you saying that no MP
should have a criminal record then it's
all you're saying yeah yeah I think I'm
saying that no we're not in pain
remember I mean I don't want to name
names for them there are members of the
House of Lords yes who have who went to
prisons and so on well they shouldn't be
there you know had she been convicted of
a speeding offence of course not of
course you shouldn't be chucked out for
that if you're convicted of something
serious like perverting the course of
justice yes well we will see she's gonna
let me remember she got unelected but as
a Labour candidate she is no longer the
Labour MP the Labour Party have kicked
her out so she won't win again but she
only got elected by 600 but I won't
again time olds out time will tell
yeah but it's Jenny her majority was
only 607 so